.
>>> HAPPY WEEK FIVE, EVERYBODY.
HOPEFULLY YOU ARE AWAKE AND
READY TO TWO LIKE THE NEW YORK
JETS RIGHT NOW.
CONGRATS TO EVERYONE WHO ROAD
WITH US LAST WEEK AND WON BIG ON
THE MIKE EVANS RECORD BREAKING
PASS.
PRETTY GOOD WEEK TO BE ALONG FOR
THE SQUAD RIDE.
THAT BEING SAID, LET'S KEEP IT
ROLLING RIGHT HERE.
YOU JUST TAPPED IN THE BR
BETTING SQUAD RIDE LIVE IN THE
BLEACHER REPORT PRESENTED BY
DRAFT KINGS.
I'M CONNOR ROGERS ALONGSIDE, A
MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
ALWAYS GOOD TO HAVE IN HERE,
GREG IVORY.
GIVE ME THE OVER S/UNDER ON THE
HOODIES HERE.
>> TAKE THE OVER.
I'M ABOUT TO GIVE OUT A HOODIE
RIGHT NOW.
I GOT MIKEY DRACO IN THE
COMMENTS SAYING WINNERS ONLY,
PLEASE.
HE CAUGHT MY ATTENTION.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
CONNOR, LET'S GET THIS THING
GOING.
>> RIGHT.
AS YOU SAY, WINNERS ONLY,
PLEASE.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR ON
THE SHOW.
WE WANT TOUCHDOWN LOCKS.
WHO IS GETTING IN THE PROMISE
LAND?
AND AS ALWAYS ON FRIDAY, WE
ASKED YOU ON SOCIAL.
WE ASKED YOU IN THE APP DROP
YOUR LOCKS OF WHO IS GOING TO
SCORE A TOUCHDOWN.
HERE IS THE MOST POPULAR PICKS
YOU SENT US.
ALVIN KAMARA AT THE TOP.
ALWAYS A POPULAR VOICE.
JUSTIN JEFFERSON BUILDING OFF
THAT GREAT ROOKIE SEASON.
STEFON DIGGS, OLD RELIABLE.
I THINK YOU WILL SEE AIM AT SOME
POINT ON THIS SHOW.
COREY DAVIS PLAYING RIGHT NOW.
HE NEEDS TO STEP UP IT IN THE
SECOND HALF.
ALL RIGHT.
AND TO GET THINGS GOING HERE,
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF OUR
FAVORITE LOCK LEGEND VIDEOS FROM
LAST WEEK THAT WE WEREN'T
FEATURED ON THE SHOW.
>> ALL RIGHT, BOYS.
>> TODAY'S NEWS IS --
>> WHO DO I THINK?
>> PASS FROM TOM BRADY THIS
WEEK.
>> THERE IS SOMETHING ON MY CAR.
>> LET'S GET OUT HERE.
>> WHO DO WE GOT?
>> PLUS 330, BABY.
LET'S GO.
>> TYLER JOHNSON.
THAT'S THEIR LOCK.
>> GRBRADY TO GRONK PLUS 300,
LET'S LOCK.
>> ALL RIGHT, GREG.
NOW YOU GOT THE HOODIES.
YOU GOT THE JERSEYS TO GIVE
AWAY.
DO WHAT YOU DO WEST.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, CONNOR.
I'M GIVING OUT HOODIES.
I'M GIVING AWAY NOT ONE BUT TWO
NFL JERSEY GIFT CARD, CONNOR.
ONE GOES TO THE LOCK LEGEND AND
ONE GOES TO A LUCKY CONGRESSMEN
TO
CONGRE
COMMENTER.
STAY HERE.
GET IN THOSE COMMENTS.
DO WHAT YOU DO.
YOU WANT A JERSEY.
YOU WANT A HOODIE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I NEED.
I NEED GIFs.
I NEED EMOJIS AND I NEED WINNERS
ONLY, PLEASE.
SOMEBODY JUST GOT A HOODIE FOR
SAYING THAT.
COME ON, GUYS.
THINK.
LET'S GO.
>> ALL RIGHT.
GET IT DONE.
WE HAVE FOUR LEGENDARY LOCK
LEGENDS TO SHOW YOU TODAY.
AS ALWAYS, IT IS THE SQUAD RIDE.
THE LAST ONE STANDING IS THE
SQUAD RIDE LEADER.
THEY GET THE TITLE.
THEY GET THE JERSEY.
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
LET'S GET THIS DONE.
OUR FIRST PITCH COMES FROM LEVY.
TELL US WHO IS SCORING A
TOUCHDOWN TODAY, LEVI.
>> WELCOME.
WE HAVE AN ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN
PROP BET.
MY MAN IS GOING TO DECIDE
BETWEEN STEFON DIGGS AND DARREN
WALLER.
COME ON, BUDDY.
STEFON DIGGS!
THERE WE HAVE IT.
STEFON DIGGS, WE'RE LOCKING IT.
>> I AM NOT A CAT GUY, BUT I AM
A STEFON DIGGS GUY.
I LIKE THE CHOICE.
MAN, THIS IS GOING TO BE
INTERESTING.
WE'VE GOT OUR FIRST DECISION OF
THE DAY.
WE NEED OUR SECOND CONTENDER.
THE SECOND PITCH FROM
PIZZAKING95.
WHAT ARE YOU SHOWING US TODAY,
PETE?
>> SO I'M DOING THE CROSS BOARD
PUZZLE THIS MORNING, AND LOOK
WHAT FALLS IN MY LAP.
37 DOWN.
TOUCHDOWN SCORE LOCK OF THE
WEEK.
LET'S SEE HERE.
NOAH FANT.
BOOK IT.
IT'S A LOCK, FOLKS.
>> YOU HEARD THE MAN.
BOOK IT.
IT'S A LOCK.
NOAH FANT, PLUS 240.
WE'RE GETTING JUICY HERE.
I LIKE IT, THOUGH.
YOU HAVE HEARD OUR FIRST TWO
PITCHES.
GREG, YOU RIDING WITH THE CATNIP
LEGEND OR THE CROSS WORD LEGEND?
>> CONNOR, BEFORE I JUMP IN
HERE, LET ME TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
EVERYBODY WATCHING, PLEASE LET
US KNOW.
LET US KNOW IF WE SHOULD RIDE
WITH STEFON DIGGS, THE CATNIP
LEGEND, OR IF WE SHOULD RIDE
WITH NOAH FANT IN THE CROSS WORD
LEGEND.
CONNOR, NOT A BIG CAT GUY
MYSELF.
NOT A BIG CAT GUY MYSELF, BUT I
MUST ADMIT I FELT THE VIBES.
FROM THE BEGINNING OF THE VIDEO,
I JUST FELT GOOD VIBES, GOOD
ENERGY.
AND THE PICK ALSO RESEMBLES
THAT.
GOOD VIBES AND GOOD ENERGY.
STEFON DIGGS TAKING ON CHIEFS.
I LIKE THAT.
PLUS MONEY.
I LIKE THAT PLUS MONEY.
SO I WILL LEAN THIS WAY.
CONNOR, WHICH WAY ARE YOU
LEANING?
>> I'M WITH YOU.
>> TO THE CROSS WORD?
>> NO.
I'M WITH YOU ALL THE WAY.
CATNIP LEGEND, I JUST LIKE THE
PICK.
I THINK FANT IS A LITTLE RISKY.
I THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE A
SHOOT-OUT, THE BILLS AND THE
CHIEFS.
SO I'M EXCITED TO WATCH DIGGS IN
THAT MATCHUP.
I WANT TO KNOW, WHAT ARE THE
COMMENTS SAYING RIGHT NOW?
WE GOT TO GET THROUGH THIS ROUND
ONE.
WHAT DO THE PEOPLE WANT?
>> I GOT PAT KENNY.
PAT KENNY SAID DIGGS AND IT
AIN'T A THING.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, PAT KENNY.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
DIGGS, SHOUT OUT TO YOU, MATT
DODGER.
I GOT ONE MORE FOR US, CONNOR.
ONE MORE.
I GOT DSEJOEBIANO.
THAT IS FOR THE PRODUCERS.
IT SAYS ME EITHER, GREG.
DOG
DOG VIBES ONLY.
I LIKE WHAT THEY DID THAT.
THAT'S ACTUALLY PRETTY FUNNY.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
BUT CONNOR, I'M LOOKING AT THE
COMMENTS AND IT LOOKS LIKE A
RUN-AWAY.
I SEE DIGGS, DIGGS, DIGGS.
ONE MORE HOODIE.
DIGGS IS AN EASY PICK.
SO THEREFORE, CONNOR, IT APPEARS
CATNIP LEGEND STEFON DIGGS IS
MOVING ON TO THE NEXT ROUND.
>> ALL RIGHT.
LEVY H., THE CATNIP LEGEND
STEFON DIGGS, THE PEOPLE ARE
RIDING WITH YOU.
GREG AND I ARE RIDING WITH YOU.
THAT'S ONLY FOR ROUND ONE.
WE STILL HAVE TWO CHALLENGERS
REMAINING.
ON TO ROUND TWO.
LET'S GET IT DONE.
OUR NEXT PITCH COMES FROM
DJONES1983.
>> WHAT'S UP, GUYS?
IT'S DEREK HERE FROM SOUTH
MISSISSIPPI.
I HAD TO DO ONE.
I'M GOING TO MAKE THIS SHORT
SINCE I'M ON A FAMILY CAMPING
TRIP.
IT'S HALLOWEEN SEASON.
YOU WANT TO BET EVERY WEEK
SCORER AND AARON RODGERS
FAVORITE RED ZONE TARGET, HE'S
NUMBER 17 ON THE FIELD.
NONE OTHER THAN DAVANTE ADAMS.
LOCK IT IN WITH CONFIDENCE AND
LET'S CASH THOSE TICKETS, BABY.
>> THE PUMPKIN LEGENDS ON THE
FAMILY VACATION.
YOU GOT TO RESPECT IT.
AND I LOVE THE PICK.
DAVANTE ADAMS, THE TARGET
MONSTER.
I LOVE THE PUMPKINS.
I LOVE THE PICK.
GREG, THIS IS GOING TO BE TOUGH.
ARE YOU RIDING WITH THE CATNIP
LEGEND, OR IS THE PUMPKIN
LEGEND, THE NEW CHALLENGER
TAKING OVER IN ROUND TWO?
>> THIS ONE IS TOUGH.
THIS ONE IS TOUGH.
IT IS SO TOUGH, CONNOR, LET ME
ASK THE PEOPLE BECAUSE I JUST
NEED THAT ENERGY FROM YOU GUYS.
YOU GUYS, LET ME KNOW.
SHOULD WE ROCK WITH DAVANTE
ADAMS HERE?
REALLY THINK ABOUT THAT.
SHOULD WE ROCK WITH DAVANTE
ADAMS HERE.
OR SHOULD WE GO WITH STEFON
DIGGS AGAINST THAT KANSAS CITY
CHIEFS DEFENSE?
CONNOR, THE VIDEO.
LET ME TALK ABOUT THE VIDEO.
IT REALLY PUT ME IN THE
HALLOWEEN MOOD.
I WAS REALLY FEELING SPOOKY, SAW
ALL THE PUMPKINS AND DIDN'T KNOW
IT WAS GOING TO POP UP AND THEN
WE SEE A NUMBER 17 WHITE PUM
N
PUMPKIN.
AND I KNOW -- I WENT TO THE
NINER GAME WHEN THEY FACED THE
PACKERS NOT TOO LONG AGO.
IT WAS TWO WEEKS AGO.
AND AARON RODGERS WAS LOOKING
FOR 17 QUITE OFTEN THROUGHOUT
THAT GAME.
>> ALL DAY.
>> I DON'T THINK ANYTHING IS
GOING TO CHANGE.
I MEAN, HE'S BEEN DOING THAT
FOR, I MEAN, HOW MANY SEASONS
NOW LOOKING FOR 17.
LIKE I JUST THINK IT'S GOING TO
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN.
I MIGHT BE LEANING TOWARDS THIS
DAVANTE ADAMS.
DAVANTE ADAMS PICK.
I DON'T KNOW, CONNOR.
WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING?
>> I'M WITH D. JONES AS WELL.
HE BROUGHT THE HOLIDAY VIBES.
HE TOOK SOME TIME-OUT ON HIS
FAMILY VACATION TO GET THIS
DONE.
WHO CARES WHAT I THINK?
THEY HAVE TO DECIDE A BRUTAL
ROUND TWO RIGHT NOW.
>> BRUTAL ROUND TWO INDEED,
CONNOR.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS, AND THE
COMMENTS ARE JUMPING, MAN.
COMMENTS ARE JUMPING.
WE GOT ANTHONY POSTING THE SAME
COMMENT.
SO THAT DOES NOT REWARD YOU A
HOODIE, ANTHONY.
BUT I WILL READ YOUR COMMENT.
HE SAYS, ADAMS IS A LOCK.
HE SAID, ADAMS IS A LOCK.
I MEAN, I DO AGREE.
SHOUT-OUT TO DAVANTE ADAMS.
HERE WE GO.
CHRIS PAUL, THE GOAT, SAYS DIGGS
ALL DAY.
DIGGS ALL DAY.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
HEY, CONNOR, IT'S BACK AND FORTH
IN THE COMMENTS.
IT'S BACK AND FORTH IN THE
COMMENTS, SO THE NEXT ONE I
CHOOSE, I'M JUST GOING TO ROCK
WITH THAT ONE, ALL RIGHT?
>> LET'S GET IT DONE.
>> I GOT JETBUTLER77 WHO SAYS
DAVANTE ADAMS, BABY.
SO THERE IT IS.
I'M CALLING IT.
PUMPKIN LEGEND DJJONES1983
DEVONTE AVANTE ADAMS IS MOVING
THE NEXT ROUND.
SHOUT-OUT TO D. JONES.
WELL DONE ON THE FAMILY
VACATION.
YOU'RE NOT THE SQUAD RIDE LEADER
YET.
IT IS TIME FOR THE WINNER TAKE
ALL.
WINNER TAKE THE TITLE.
WINNER TAKE THE JERSEY.
YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS RIGHT NOW.
NEXT UP IS COZYCOZA.
FINAL ROUND.
LET'S SEE THE PICK.
>> ALL RIGHTY, GUYS.
WE NEED SOME LOCKS THIS WEEKEND
TO GET PUT ON DECK.
WHAT OPTIONS DO WE HAVE?
NO WAY.
HONESTLY STILL NOT SURE WHAT
SPORT THAT IS.
TEMPTING.
OH, THERE WE GO.
AND WHAT DO WE HAVE TO PUT ON
HERE?
>> I'M DIGGING IT.
LET'S GO.
>> THE RECORD LEGEND.
MY MAN HAS GOT QUITE THE
COLLECTION RIGHT THERE.
I LOVE THE CREATIVITY.
WE TALKED ABOUT ALVIN KAMARA AT
THE TOP OF THE SHOW.
THE FAVORITE PICK.
HE WAS THE LEADER UP THERE.
IT'S KIND OF A BLOOD BATH.
IT IS KIND OF A ONE AND TWO.
DAVANTE ADAMS, PUMPKIN LEGEND,
RECORD LEGEND.
>> CONNOR, LET ME TALK TO THE
PEOPLE.
YOU GUYS LET ME KNOW WHICH WAY
WE SHOULD -- YOU GUYS LET ME
KNOW WHICH WAY WE SHOULD ROCK
BECAUSE THIS IS THE SQUAD RIDE.
THIS ISN'T GREG'S RIDE.
YOU GUYS GET IN THE COMMENTS AND
TELL ME WHICH WAY WE SHOULD
LEAN.
I PERSONALLY WANT TO LEAN
TOWARDS DAVANTE ADAMS.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT, CONNOR.
EVEN MY GUY, THE PUMPKIN LEGEND
HIMSELF, DJ JONES SAID DAVANTE
ADAMS IS AARON RODGERS FAVORITE
TARGET IN THE RED ZONE.
>> FAVORITE TARGET ANYWHERE THEY
GO.
ANYWHERE ON THE FIELD FOR 17 IS
AARON RODGERS FAVORITE TARGET.
BUT I'M LEANING TOWARD DEVOAVAN
ADA
ADAMS.
LOVE THE VIDEO.
LOVE THE CREATIVITY.
THAT IS ALSO A GOOD THING, TOO.
BUT LOOK AT THE ODDS.
I'M GOING WITH THE MINUS 140.
GIVE IT TO ME.
WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING,
CONNOR?
>> I'M GOING TO STAY LOCAL TO
THE PUMPKIN, RIGHT?
I'M GOING TO STAY LOYAL TO THE
DEVOAVANTE ADAMS PICK.
I KNOW THE SAINTS HAVE BEEN A
WEIRD TEAM THIS YEAR.
GREEN BAY, YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT
YOU ARE GOING TO GET, BUT YOU
ALWAYS FEEL GOOD ABOUT ONE THING
WITH THEM.
THAT'S THE CONNECTION OF ROGERS
AND ADAMS AND THE WAY THEY GET
IT DONE.
YOU'RE ROLLING WITH ADAMS.
I'M ROLLING WITH ADAMS.
IS THE COMMENTS SECTION WITH US?
IS THE PUMPKIN SQUAD RIDE
CONTENDER GETTING ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE RIGHT NOW?
>> HEY, THEY ARE BACK AND FORTH
IN THE COMMENTS.
I LOVE RANCH ROCKING WITH ALVIN
KAMARA.
HE HAS A GIF HERE.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU ILOVERANCH.
HE SAYS, THIS GUY, WHAT A
DAVANTE ADAMS GIF.
THERE IT IS.
YOU WALK AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
LARRY HALL OF FAME SAYS ADAMS IS
ROCKING WITH ADAMS.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU, LARRY.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I GOT ONE MORE.
ONE MORE.
JES
JESSE24 SAYS ADAMS, HEY, IT'S A
RUN-AWAY, CONNOR.
I'M GOING TO JUST START GIVING
AWAY HOODIES.
HERE WE GO.
IHEARTSTEVE SAYS ADAMS -- NO,
I'M GOING TO STOP.
THEY'RE GOING TO CUT ME OFF.
SO I'M JUST GOING TO STOP BEFORE
THEY DO.
YOU GUYS ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS,
CONNOR?
THAT MEANS THAT THE PUMPKIN
LEGEND, DAVANTE ADAMS, MY GUY
DJONES1983 IS THE WINNER OF THIS
WEEK'S SQUAD RIDE.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
WE WILL SEND YOU SOMETHING,
DJJONES.
AND YOU GUYS GET IN THE -- GET
ON DRAFT KINGS AND BET THE SQUAD
RIDE.
SEND US YOUR SHOTS OF YOUR BETS.
LET'S GET RICH THIS SUNDAY.
SEND US YOUR VIDEOS AND YOUR
CELEBRATIONS.
CONNOR, HOW ARE YOU FEELING
ABOUT THIS DAVANTE ADAMS PICK?
>> WE LOVE IT.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A SNEAKY
GOOD GAME.
THE BENGALS ARE 3-1.
THE BENGAL WILLS BE FEEDING OFF
THAT HOME CROWD, WHICH IS GOOD
FOR THIS PICK.
THE PACKERS WILL BE THROWING THE
BALL TO DAVANTE ADAMS, THE
TARGET MONSTER THAT HE ALWAYS
IS.
LET'S CASH IN SOME CHECKS HERE
AND MAKE SOME MONEY ON THE
DAVANTE ADAMS PICK.
I'M LOVING IT.
WE'RE NOT DONE.
WE HAVE A SQUAD RIDE LEADER.
WE HAVE COMMUNITY BETS.
WE GOT LOCKS TO GIVE AWAY.
WE GOT THAT JERSEY.
LET'S HAVE SOME FUN.
LET'S GET INTO THE COMMUNITY
CONTEST AS WE ALWAYS GO.
HANG OUT STREAMING THE VR APP.
YOU KNOW ABOUT THIS ALREADY.
WE ASK YOU EVERY WEEK, WHAT DID
YOU LEARN FROM THE PREVIOUS
WEEKS.
WHAT ARE YOU PICKING UP FROM
THIS NFL SEASON?
WE PICKED OUR TWO FAVORITE
COMMENTS AND WE WANT TO KNOW
WHAT YOU THINK.
GREG, LET'S GET RIGHT INTO IT.
>> I NEED YOU GUYS TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME WHICH OF
THESE IS THE BETTER TAKE.
I'M GIVING A HOODIE TO WHOEVER
YOU CHOOSE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE FIRST
COMMENT FROM MY GUY DT.
I'M GOING TO JUST CALL HIM DT,
CONNOR.
HE SAID THE DOGS HAVE NO
TRAINING THIS YEAR.
KILLING PARLAYS LEFT AND RIGHT.
SOMEBODY CALL THE DOG WHISPERER,
PLEASE.
HOLD ON.
THERE IS NOTHING WRONG WITH A
LITTLE DOG BARKING.
THAT'S THE PLUS MONEY.
ISN'T THAT WHAT WE LIKE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I'M ALL ABOUT THIS RIGHT NOW.
I LOVE WHEN THE SAVE MONEY GETS
NUKED.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES THIS FUN.
LISTEN, NO RISK IT, NO BISCUIT.
LET'S KEEP IT MOVING.
>> HEY, PIERRE, THIS IS NOT THE
TAG, BUT THIS IS ACTUALLY
SOMEBODY WHO COMMENTED.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
HERE IT IS.
IT'S LIKE THIS EVERY YEAR.
WHEN IN DOUBT TAKE THE POINTS IN
THE NFL ANY GIVEN SUNDAY.
WOW.
I GUESS THIS IS JUST A DOG
BARKING SUNDAY THIS WEEK.
HUH, CONNOR?
>> AND GOOD FOR THEM.
GREAT JOB BRINGING SOME RATIONAL
THINKING TO THE SQUAD RIDE,
RIGHT?
LISTEN, THERE IS NOTHING WRONG
WITH TAKING THE POINTS OR TAKING
THE UPSET.
MAKE THAT MONEY BACK.
HAVE SOME FUN.
WE HAVE SEEN IT WEEK AFTER WEEK
SO FAR.
THERE HAS BEEN TONS OF UPSETS,
WHETHER IT IS COLLEGE, WHETHER
IT IS NFL.
WE'RE HAVING FUN WITH IT.
THAT IS GREAT BETTING ADVICE FOR
THIS WEEK.
>> YES, SIR.
CONNOR, I'M IN THE COMMENTS,
MAN.
I DON'T HAVE THE HANDY DANDY
iPAD TODAY, BUT I HAVE HIS
COUSIN, THE HANDY DANDY PHONE.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS SEEING WHAT
THEY'RE LOOKING AT.
NO, DOG, SO I FEEL LIKE HE'S
VIBING WITH US.
AND WE LIKE THE DOGS.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU, JJ.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
ALSO, DT, YOU ARE WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE FOR YOUR TAKE.
LET ME GIVE OUT SOME MORE
HOODIES.
HEY, PIERRE, WORD UP.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I GOT ONE MORE IN ME, CONNOR.
IHEARTSTEVE 0704 SAYS HEY,
PIERRE KNOWS WHAT'S UP.
THAT'S A TAG.
SO THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE ARE VIBING
IN THE COMMENTS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
BOLDEST BET.
WELL DONE.
BUT IT IS TIME FOR OUR BOLDEST
BETS OF THE WEEK.
WE HAVE OUR COMMENTS CONTEST.
LISTEN, IT IS BAD LUCK TO TALK
ABOUT A HOT STREAK.
I AM HEATING UP ON THE BOLDEST
BETS.
THE TWO TOUCHDOWN SCORES HAVE
BEEN GOOD TO ME.
LET'S KEEP THIS GOING ON THE
BOLDEST BETS.
GREG, WHAT DO WE NEED FROM THE
PEOPLE DURING THIS TIME OF THE
SHOW?
>> GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL
ME.
IF YOU ARE RIDING WITH ME OR IF
YOU ARE RIDING WITH CONNOR,
PROBABLY RIDE WITH CONNOR.
HE'S BEEN HOT.
>> TIME TO COOL OFF.
I'M NERVOUS, MAN.
I'M NERVOUS.
>> CONNOR, WHO YOU GOT?
TALK TO US.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WE HIT ON MIKE WILLIAMS TWO
WEEKS AGO, TYREEK HILL LAST
WEEK.
WE'RE JUST GOING TO KIND OF, U
UNFORTUNATELY BE HARSH WITH THE
HOUSTON TEXANS HERE.
I DON'T THINK IT REALLY MATTERS.
I DON'T THINK HOUSTON CAN PUT UP
ANY POINTS ON NEW ENGLAND.
SO WE ARE GOING PATRIOTS TO WIN
BY 19 TO 24 POINTS.
ESSENTIALLY A BLOW-OUT.
GREG, WHAT DO YOU GOT FOR US
THIS WEEK?
>> CONNOR, I HAVE TO TAP IN WITH
MY GUY MATT DODGER.
SAW HIM IN THE COMMENTS.
HAD TO ASK HIM, HEY, MAN, WHAT'S
A BOLD BET THAT THE PEOPLE
SHOULD RIDE THIS WEEK?
HE TOLD ME, DON'T GO FAR BECAUSE
HE'S FROM L.A.
HE SAID, LET'S GO TO L.A.
LET'S GO TO L.A.
CHARGERS/BROWNS, TAKE THE
ALTERNATE SPREAD.
BROWNS MINUS FOUR.
CHARGERS ARE COMING OFF AN
EMOTIONAL GAME.
BROWNS ARE COMING OFF A HARD
FOUGHT ROAD GAME.
THEY'RE THE DOGS HERE, CONNOR.
WE WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT THE
DOGS.
THEY ARE THE DOGS.
MINUS FOUR, PLUS 210.
TAKE IT.
SHOUT-OUT TO MY GUY MATT DODGER.
WE'RE ROCKING.
WE'RE ROLLING.
>> I LIKE IT.
LISTEN, THIS IS A GOOD BROWNS
TEAM.
CHARGERS, YOUNG, FUN TEAM.
WE KNOW THEY WILL BE FEEDING OFF
THE HOME VIBES A LITTLE BIT, BUT
THAT IS NOT A LOT OF POINTS, MY
MAN.
WHAT ARE THE PEOPLE SAYING?
ARE THEY LEANING ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER?
>> CONNOR IS HOT, BUT GREG IS
CONSISTENT.
ANTHONY, SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
THAT WAS LITERALLY THE FIRST
THING I SAW, CONNOR.
YEAH.
I DON'T KNOW WHY I READ THAT
ONE.
BUT SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
HERE WE GO.
JASON SAYS BROWNS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
CONNOR IS EN FUEGO.
NEAL DEUCE, SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
TRASHED SAYS LFG.
THOSE ARE GOOD VIBES.
CONNOR HAS THE LOCK.
DBOY22 SAYS CONNOR HAS THE LOCK.
ONE MORE.
I GOT GIVE ME THE BROWNS.
CONNORS PICK A LITTLE TOO RISKY.
I'M SORRY.
THE ENGLISH THERE WAS -- BAD
VIBES THERE ANYWAY, CONNOR.
LET'S JUST KEEP IT GOING.
>> MAN, I LOVE IT.
DID YOU GIVE AWAY THAT JERSEY
YET, BY THE WAY?
I DON'T WANT THAT JERSEY IN YOUR
POCKET TOO LONG.
>> LET ME GIVE IT AWAY.
LOGAN GOT TO ROLL WITH GREG.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY.
AND I GOT MYSTICAL WHO SAYS, I'M
GOING WITH CONNOR ON THIS ONE.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
THE OTHER PERSON GOT AWAY WITH A
JERSEY.
>> WE GOT THE RISK TAKERS.
WE GOT THE PEOPLE GOING WITH THE
BROWNS.
WE GOT ALL KINDS OF GOOD THINGS
GOING RIGHT NOW WHICH OF COURSE
MEANS GOOD LUCK WITH YOUR
WAGERS.
WE WANT DAVANTE ADAMS TO SCORE.
WE WANT THE LOCK LEGENDS TO KEEP
THOSE VIDEOS COMING.
CONGRATS TO ALL OUR HOODIE
WINNERS, JERSEY WINNERS.
HAVE NO FEAR.
BR BETTING IS GOING TO GET BACK
TO YOU.
THANKS TO EVERYONE WHO
COMMENTED.
THE COMMENTS SECTION HAS BEEN
AWESOME EVERY WEEK WE HAVE DONE
THIS SHOW.
THANKS TO OUR LEGENDS.
PIZZA KING 95, THE CROSS WORD
GENIUS.
DJONES 1983 BRINGING IT FROM
VACATION FROM THE PUMPKIN, AND
HE'S OUT SQUAD RIDE LEADER AND
OF COURSE COZY.
ENJOY YOUR FOOTBALL SUNDAY.
DROP YOUR REAL-TIME TAKES
STREAMING THE VR APP AND FOLLOW
US, ESPECIALLY IF YOU WANT TO
KEEP UP WITH GREG, FOLLOW THOSE
STORIES ALL DAY.
ALWAYS ENTERTAINING.
ALONGSIDE GREG IVORY, I'M CONNOR
ROGERS.
SEE YOU SAME TIME, SAME PLACE
NEXT WEEK.